[Music]
do you remember the first time you saw
that Ines were four kids who grow up
loving dinosaurs the Jurassic movies are
really the vehicle for them to see their
dreams realize the Jurassic movies have
always been suspenseful and exciting
we're telling the next chapter this
story takes dinosaurs and takes Jurassic
where it's never gone before we're
literally blowing up the island
in this movie if we have a new director
Juan Antonio Bayona I love playing with
suspense
I like intensity and I love to make the
audience feel the total experience he's
genius when it comes to frightening
people there's dinosaurs everywhere and
they're flipping out and killing people
let's go it was important to us that the
story be balanced on the characters some
of whom we know and some of whom were
just meeting Jeff Goldblum not gonna lie
that's pretty awesome
Here I am talking about dinosaurs again
in this Jurassic world you will see more
dinosaurs than you've ever seen before
on this movie we are dealing with real
animatronic dinosaurs it looks like a
real dinosaur I couldn't help but freak
out the entire time the challenge of
making a sequel is finding the right
balance between what people are
expecting and what people will be
surprised by
this movie is different it's going to be
intense and pretty spectacular
[Music]
that was my best acting
it's like nothing you've ever seen
before
man it's Jurassic
this is gonna be awesome
[Music]
[Music]